you know the last time that Republicans
controlled the house was 2011 to 2019.
and I think it's important to remind
ourselves the things that the House of
Representatives focused on and did
during the time that Republicans last
controlled the house because yesterday I
did the segment for you about things are
very quickly getting very stupid in the
house now that Republicans control the
House of Representatives and many of you
wrote to me and I could tell that there
was sort of a lack of awareness of what
things were like during that period that
Republicans previously controlled the
house there was a total lack of doing
anything helpful to the American people
during that period of time and forget
about lack of helpful
think about the damage that was actually
done by Republicans controlling the
house for that period of time
Republicans in the house when they
controlled it voted roughly 50 times to
repeal the Affordable Care Act now you
could depending on how you want to slice
and dice it in the ways in which they
did it the number might be higher than
50 or lower roughly 50 times in some way
shape or form Republicans voted to
repeal the Affordable Care Act that was
one where way that they spent resources
when they last controlled the house had
they succeeded it would have resulted in
millions of people losing health care
including people with pre-existing
conditions now thankfully the repeal
effort failed but the fact that
Republicans were willing to strip people
of their health care should be
concerning to all of us you might
remember also at the beginning of Donald
Trump's term in 2017 they proposed that
other health care plan which would have
led to tens of millions of Americans
losing Health Care coverage thankfully
that didn't become law but that was a
priority for a formerly
republican-controlled House Republicans
when they last controlled the house
systematically rolled back environmental
regulations they withdrew from the Paris
climate agreement they quite literally
took actions that worsened the prospects
for Homo sapiens on planet Earth they
gutted the epa's budget
making it harder for the EPA to protect
air to protect water but they were in
control these are the things they did
they were a disaster on immigration
including separation of families at the
border caging of children although they
could have moved forward on doing
something more permanent with DACA they
didn't even though they controlled the
house and they could have taken some of
the credit and then of course on taxes
we can't forget the attempted tax bills
Republicans tried to pass but failed to
pass and also what they did pass
including in 2017 under Donald Trump
exploding the deficit large portion of
the benefits going to the top one
percent that's the record of Republicans
last time they controlled the house and
there's sometimes enlightened centrists
as I call them who love to say well
divided government is good it's good
when one party controls the Senate and
the other the house so that nobody gets
too much power it's it's meaningless
pablum it's just something people say to
sound like they are thinking critically
and moderate and whatever else when
Republicans get control of a legislative
body they do horrible things now when
Democrats control have control they
often fail to accomplish things as well
but there's really no comparison here
and so when we think back to that period
of time it really serves as a disturbing
preview of what we're up against over
the next two years
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the New Year stay staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com
Pacman the link is down below